okay you're okay I am are you sure
definitely okay I'm just scared dramatic
video shows an intense Rescue of a woman
who was abducted when an unknown man
drove off with her in the back seat
it happened near Lodi Wisconsin in the
early morning hours of January 14th
Columbia County dispatch received a
9-1-1 call from the victim who said she
was sleeping in the back seat of her car
at a truck stop when a stranger took the
wheel and began to drive off thank you
sure yes I just can't because he was
driving like crazy and I couldn't I
couldn't talk with him he didn't want to
stop I don't know his crazy world what
happened with him according to court
documents the driver later identified as
51 year old Kyle Wagner told the victim
there was quote a conspiracy and that
people wanted to kill them so he was
saving her the woman woke up to a
high-speed chase that led Sheriff's
deputy
[Music]
dash camera footage shows parts of the
high-speed chase where Wagner speeds
down the center of lodi's Main Street
even as the tires are deflated on the
vehicle
pull through the intersection
heading towards quick trip northfall
after that dash cam video catches the
vehicle driving on the wrong side of the
road
[Music]
it's then that First Responders use a
Chase tactic forcing the vehicle into
the guard rail it crashes then becomes
Airborne before the airbags are deployed
[Music]
foreign
after the crash multiple sheriff's
deputies rushed toward the vehicle
helping the victim out of the back seat
officials then instruct Wagner to put
his hands up as they work to get him out
of the car keep your hands up don't you
dare move
my head
again eventually Wagner makes his way
out of the vehicle through the passenger
door
two hands not resistance
once he's safely outside officials put
Wagner in handcuffs
I'm not doing anything
oh
yeah
as sheriff's deputies search Wagner the
victim can be heard saying she does not
know who he is and that she is scared
who's this guy you're okay I am are you
sure definitely okay I'm just scared
court documents show Wagner admitted to
using Fentanyl and meth within 24 hours
of the incident he's now being held on a
forty thousand dollar cash Bond and
faces multiple charges including false
imprisonment and vehicle operator
eluding an officer reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie